Cameron Mathison thought it would be a
good idea to step into the ring as a
mixed martial arts fighter and fight for
real listen when I get a cam cam
challenge I literally have to take it
but I got to be honest I was looking
forward to this one of course it didn't
end well
it's the latest of the insane challenges
that we have this man faced tonight Ken
camp become an Ultimate Fighter
I'm outside highest on MMA academy in
North Hollywood and I'm gonna get some
training from MMA star Joe
Gaddy Stephenson he's gonna show me a
thing or two so I could take on
Johnathan Tucker from Kingdom and we're
gonna go at it in the cage oh man am I
ready for this wish me luck please Joe
daddy's been kingdoms fight coordinator
for three years now and well I'm an
athletic guy but mixed martial arts yeah
this sounds like a good idea
so now let's explain what we're gonna do
all right what do we got the drill is
not to let him clinch me what does
clinch me oh where they would be well
Donnie's I don't want to let that happen
to me after gearing up now what we need
to do is go rinse this off me not oh is
it cuz he's got feet all over and an
hour of training later I was ready to
take on Tucker
what's the worst injury that you've
received fighting MMA the big injury I
had on our show was I getting my I
opened up I had Joe daddy pouring super
glue into the eyebrow trying to seal it
shut and that's when I realized I was up
against a hardcore competitor for his
role as a pro fighter on Kingdom Tucker
spends a lot of time working out so I
knew it was time for Plan B intimidation
boom wow that is intimidating right come
on look good my mom
gentlemen good clean fight for love now
if you like you
sorry I got looks like that headbutt
right there that was an accident but the
blood coming out of Tucker's head was
real and my worst fear come true but
Tucker's a great guy and assured me it's
all part of getting in the cage
head-to-head combat babe
but without a clinch we still didn't
have a winner so Joe came up with a
tiebreaker scare her challenge is gonna
be
you rotating around my body as I stand
still how many rotations completely
around will be a win very good don't
have to rush I am a winner you sure you
okay guys at home this thing is no joke
cam is real but camp cannot take down
Jonathan Tucker it's true okay thanks
for joining us men you guys are hardcore
great Bonecrusher the tattoo held sure
you did yeah man got a little crazy is
everything cool everything is completely
fine Jonathan is awesome he's all fixed
up he's ready to go great guy all right
cuz if he cuts up I got your back yeah